in terms of sex and relationship it's so
different because mad they would pick
anyone to have sex with because men just
have a high sex drive but when it comes
to relationship I believe and then I'm a
lot more picky they'll say they don't
want a woman that has too much body care
they don't want a woman with kids
standard that we set for ourselves is
literally does he treat me well is he
gonna be a good father before you get to
that point of I would like to get in a
relationship with this guy that guy
would have to qualify some requirements
some preferences in the first place
women will speak to guys and they'll be
banging the guy that they really like